cette vidéo n'est pas sponsorisée par
les produits laitiers tu vas vite
comprendre pourquoi depuis des années on
nous dit que manger des produits
laitiers c'est indispensable les
scientifiques sont pas tous complètement
d'accord là-dessus mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'information elle vient pas
d'eux elle vient de l'industrie laitière
leur principal argument c'est que les
produit laitiers c'est la meilleure
source de calcium et ben ça
factuellement c'est faux du calcium il y
en a dans plein d'autres aliments juste
c'est pas forcément dans des trucs que
les enfants aiment manger genre du chou
des épinards des brocolis par exemple
donc leur filet du yaourt c'est juste
c'est plus facile quoi oui mais le
calcium du lait il est mieux absorbé par
l'organisme ah encore faux ce qu'on sait
par contre c'est que pour le bien de la
planète et de notre santé on a vachement
intérêt à diminuer les produits
d'origine animale genre le lait et puis
les produits laitiers genre les crèmes
les yaourts et cetera enfin les produits
laitiers transformés ils sont souvent
plein de graisse et plein de sucre et ça
est-ce que j'ai besoin de dire que c'est
pas bon pour la santé il y a même des
études qui ont montré que ça
augmenterait le risque de cancer
colorectal donc nos amis pour la vie
vite fait quand même